[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice dr john deloney ramsey
personality
explodingly popular podcast i don't know
if that's how you say it or not but
it's going big going fast as his and you
can join him at dr john delonay you can
call into his show i'll go and tell you
what that is if you want to call if you
can't get in here today he's here to
help
you with your life your money uh
boundaries relationships
anxiety whatever it is you're dealing
with and we'll talk about your money too
which is kind of all the same thing
really but
uh his number if you want to jump in on
the doc on the john delony show is you
can just send him an email at ask
john ramsey solutions dot com
or voicemail and we'll make you into a
caller at eight
four four six nine three thirty two
one the phone number here if you want to
talk about your life today as dr john
and i are with you is triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five the call is free and
some say it's worth
considerably less than you paid for it
all right jeremy is with us
in sacramento hey jeremy how can we help
today
how are you doing thanks for having me
on gentlemen sure um
me and my wife uh actually started
following you at the end of february
this year so just a little over a month
ago
wow and um kind of what got me going is
when
i did my taxes and realized that we made
decent money but had no money to uh show
for it at the end
and when uh that's a different level of
disgust isn't
it yes it is um yeah so
uh ended up uh purchasing your program
doing all the on uh i fell in love with
it showed my wife she fell in love with
it because we
both kind of felt the same way for a
little bit after adding up all of our
debt snowballs we were about
97 thousand dollars in bet um
one of which was my 800 a month truck
payment
so within the first two weeks i was able
to
sell my truck and uh only ended up
eating about three hundred dollars
wow so we were super blessed in that
um and so now we've been doing that how
much did the truck sell for
forty six five also half of your debt
was pick up
yes and so i had purchased it for about
50 uh
about two years before you did okay
yeah and so we've been hitting it this
month
and um we're down to about 29
000 left so we're going to be paying off
and so
uh we're super grateful for you guys to
kind of just lead us in the right
direction
and you're on fire i love it my question
is
we're still hopefully by the end of july
we'll be completely
out of debt and so approximately october
we should have our three months
saved for retirement i work for a
company where they
take out for pension we have to
contribute nine and a half percent
um that they pull out and you know i'll
get it when i retire
but for the 15 percent um when i go
to re to for investing how would i
contribute that
because i uh because they don't match or
anything so i'll be pulling it right
into my 401k roth
well here's my theory on it okay okay
and then you can you can decide what you
want to do but here's how i came up with
the answer and then
i'll give you the answer the pension
what it's invested in is number one
not in your control so the rates of
return that you make versus you can
select a mutual fund in a 401k
and so if you don't like this one you
can get another one and so you have a
sense of control
and if you got a bad investment you can
move it around with the pension it just
is what it is you're stuck with it
problem number one problem number two
with a pension
is it's not in your name if you have a
401k and your company goes broke the
401k is in your name
it's not an asset of the company you get
all your money
if your pension is if your company goes
broke and you have a pension
it is an asset on their books and you
may get
zero that's a possibility
if they went broke okay so point being
of both of these things is you're not in
control of your destiny
but it is your money nine and a half
percent that you're putting in
mandatory every month and so i want to
count
some of it towards the 15 but because of
those two problems
i'm gonna count only about half of it uh
so let's just call it five percent and
so now you need to do ten percent
otherwise
and that that because i want you to have
substantial money that is
in your control and that ten percent
will still get you there does that make
any sense
yes sir that's why i was just trying to
look for a number i wasn't sure if it
was we were up as high as like 13 or 14
to balance the difference but
there's no magic there's no magic i just
made that
up okay uh years ago i made it up but i
mean
but the reasoning behind it is i'm going
to count it at about 50
because it's got these two major
problems where you're not in control
and you could lose it uh where with your
401k you're in control
and you don't lose it in the event the
company goes belly up so we give it some
weight but not not 100
on the dollar weight do companies have
an excellency
a financial access exigency is that that
word
they have the ability to roll that
pension out of where it sits
and pay their bills with it if not if
they got no if it got too bad
no it's held and they're highly
regulated and how
even a pension plan is yeah and how you
can invest it which is also actually one
of the problems
because they can't invest it as well
because it's considered too aggressive
as you would with mutual funds okay and
so the returns are usually in the six to
seven percent range
rather than in the ten to twelve percent
range okay and so you're not making as
much on your money either
but uh they don't have access to it to
you know to pay payroll friday
or something like that but it isn't it
is an asset on the books
their books not yours and so because you
don't have this ownership position
you know the kind of the old almost
legendary story in a movie or something
like the mind went broke and papa lost
his pension right you know well that's
exactly what happened
can they can they borrow money against
that since it's an asset no
so it's just a floating it's just a
thing over there it's a bookkeeping
entry
but the problem is the ownership and the
regulation
okay you know it's over regulated so
they're they're they'd have to dumb down
what they're doing right and uh because
to keep them from
being stupid being stupid with it and
screwing you up right since you don't
have control of it
but the unintended consequences is it's
this watered-down rates of return
uh and then i didn't know i didn't know
companies that hold it as an asset
it's not well i mean it's not an asset
that's usable which makes it almost
worse it's just like a balloon but the
problem is still in lies that that you
know the mind went broke and papa lost
his pensions thing still
is a real thing you know and some of the
pensions have
good insurance on them and all kinds of
there's all kinds of ways that you're
probably not going to lose your money
but i mean unions they mishandle them
sometimes the unions are notorious for
that
or municipalities go bankrupt yeah i
mean you've seen detroit and
birmingham and some of the other areas i
mean they've had real issues
and um even some of these states are
very poorly run well especially if
they're bonded out that man and then
the interest rates come in that's gonna
be jammed up on their dadgum
you know they're the way they run
business sucks uh the business aspect of
running the state the governing
of the state is done poorly so you just
have to you know
you don't you can't automatically assume
it's gold it's not gold
but it's probably okay i'm not trying to
be melodramatic
but but i just don't count it at 100
when we're doing the calculation
because i really just like this whole
thing of if i know
i am responsible for my turnout of my
destiny
then that is one of the keys
for it to turn out well because you got
to be invested in if you're waiting on
someone else to do this for you whether
it's the government your company your
pension
and and somehow you can relinquish the
responsibility for your future to
someone else you
that's the moment you got screwed when
you gave up the belief
that you are responsible for your future
you have to get up
leave the cave kill something and drag
it home hustle
grind get your butt on fire get some
stuff happening
you control your destiny
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five katrina is in detroit
hi katrina how can we help
hey super nervous to talk to you guys um
my question is
i recently just got engaged and i would
like to start planning for
our wedding but the problem is is i'm a
hot mess and in debt
so i want to be responsible while still
trying to pay off debt and not get
further into debt but also still plan a
good wedding
good for you so any tips for advice for
trying to get a good budget number
and how to move forward as well as
talking to my now fiance of how
we want to tackle debt after we get
married okay
what do you make a year around 70.
what does he make a year around 30.
okay and uh how much hot mess dad have
you got
uh 105. and that's in what
uh a little bit of everything hospital
credit cards
what's the big one student loan student
loans how much
78 78 how much you owe in the car
no car no car okay so credit card
student loans and other miscellaneous
crap is the other
uh twenty some odd thousand dollars yep
okay how old are you
27. i had to think about it what do you
do for a living i'm sorry
say that again you're how old 27 27 okay
27.
okay what do you do for a living
research your researcher okay okay good
yeah
okay so what do you think
the budget ought to be for the wedding
you're paying for a hundred percent of
it right
correct okay the two of you are mom and
dad aren't helping yes
correct okay i was thinking around 20
but as soon as i start thinking towards
20
i'm like that's a student loan i could
pay off so i wanted to get a firm
good number but i can just like this is
what we're planning we're just going to
think sunk on it and this is what it is
and then just move forward from there
all right the average wedding in america
last year was 28 000.
that means that a considerable number of
people spent more than that
and a considerable number of people
spent a lot less than that
the average household income in america
last year was right around
60 000. so the typical family is
spending
a maximum or an average of half of their
annual income
on a wedding but they don't have a
hundred and five thousand dollars worth
of debt hanging over their head
either necessarily and some of those mom
and dad are paying for it
so we have to factor all of that stuff
in but that's just some numbers to keep
into consideration
okay got a lot of young people in my
building here
uh a lot of them getting married every
year
while they're trying to get out of debt
so they face the exact same equation you
have
and i have personally attended many many
many
wonderful weddings in the 10 000 and
under range
okay perfect so i'm making this up i'm
just throwing out some
numbers there so i threw out 28 i threw
out 10.
you threw out 20. you made
you got a household income when you're
married of a hundred
but you got a hundred and five thousand
dollars hanging over your head so that's
affecting this decision the beauty of
your question is once you make this
decision
you set a wedding budget you stick to it
a full breakdown you run a wedding like
it's a project
for research okay and uh then you can
stick to it it's not going to randomly
happen in other words in other words if
you say
we're going to spend uh 12 500
i don't care i just made that number up
then you have to decide okay how much on
the reception
how much on the videographer uh how much
on the location
uh how much are we going to put into the
how many groomsmen and
bridesmaids and gifts and
uh you know you got you kind of line
item out this budget because your
biggest item
in most weddings is the reception
budget-wise
i've i've been involved in the
background way in the background
uh of three ramsey weddings uh in the
last few years and
but we did run them on a budget and we
did run them like a project
and um because that's the only way dad's
putting his freaking money in there
so um but the whole point is you you do
all this and then it takes the pressure
off
because we're going to spend x number of
dollars on the dress which means you're
not going to spend 2x
and you don't have to make all these
ambivalent stress-based decisions over
and over and over again once you make
the one decision
does that make sense completely so i
think you're 20 is a little high
but not way high i don't think you're
crazy
and once you make the decision once you
make that decision have some peace with
yourself yeah right
you know you tap out on other people's
expectations because some people are
going to think you spent too much some
people don't think you didn't spend
enough and it's not their dead gum
wedding
i like that and there's there's
dave help me with this um and and
katrina will benefit from the
conversation
i i i feel this tension which is she
owes 105 000 bucks man you got to get
this thing taken care of and
the math part of me says go to the
justice of the peace
work really hard to get your debt paid
off and then throw a big party in a
couple years
then there's another side of me that
says we have stripped our culture
of every sort of important
heritage ritual we've just sucked the
soul out of our culture
and i would say no if you're going to if
you're going to do something right
do a wedding upright yeah because you're
going to do it once and you're going to
do it big and it's
going to be something that you it's
going to be a touchstone for the rest of
your life
help me find some wisdom in between
those two things i think you're exactly
right
okay and so the point is you don't go
crazy you're not trying to make a
reality show out of this dead gum thing
right on the one hand
but now if someone calls and says uh
look we're bound in the tournament we
both just want to do the jp
we're just going to get to go we're
going to go to the preacher's office and
and get this done
i'm not going to be mad at you for doing
that that's your choice right but i also
don't want to say as your financial
advisor you have to do that
because otherwise you're unwise okay
because part of personal finance is
this is a milestone and she needs a ring
and she needs a wedding and she needs a
bride's address you know and and there's
a milestone here
and there's a celebration around this
historical precedent for
for as long as there have been as long
as there have been weddings they've been
a big deal right you know there you go
right
in funerals right and births i mean
these are the tuning forks of life they
they reset your head and so i think you
need to have a wedding personally i i
would i mean
if you were my child my one of my grown
kids that came to me i'd say you need to
spend something on it
but let's not go hog wild i'm kind of my
head just the math that we've all
bounced around katrina
i'm bouncing between 10 and 15 in my
head right now
that makes sense but if you come back
and say you know we talked about it
we're going to do seven
i'm cool with that are we going to do 17
i'm cool with that but what i do want
you to do is i want you to set that
number
pay cash for it pay cash for it be free
after that
because you're going to say you know a
budget that you set
and are in control of the number then
sets you free to make a lot of decisions
on what you're
not going to do you're not going to
overspend you know
this is not an academy award motion
picture we need a few videos
hey katrina does this guy like you
yes a lot i hope so you know
a lot uh he's a good guy
so i don't want you to walk into your
wedding as though you
are the ball and chain here financially
i want you to walk in with your head
held high he has agreed to take you and
all of you
and then you all are going to work on
this debt together if you walk in
already ashamed of who you are in your
financial position
that's going to start your marriage off
a step down and then you're going to
have this weird inequity thing that's
going to go on it's going to rattle
around through your
relationship for years to come walk in
with your head held high you put all the
money on the table
made some mistakes but i am willing to
own that and we're going to attack them
and it's in the past the rear view
mirror is smaller than the windshield
that's right that's right but go in with
your head held high he loves you and
he's committed to you and all of you and
y'all going to do this thing together
yeah you're
awesome thank you for calling in that's
a really good question to talk through
um and and you know i've just watched
our culture strip it all away
and and well i mean i've had people come
in and go
my wife's gonna sell her diamond ring
for the dead snowball and i'm like no
right
but it's even further like if it's a
forty eight thousand dollar diamond ring
we'll talk about it but i mean if it's a
forty if it's a typical
you know diamond ring for no you keep
your dadgum ring
it doesn't ten thousand dollars out of a
hundred when you make 100 doesn't change
this equation much by the way
correct correct but there's something
about knocking down
i don't know this is where i can get off
the rails there's something about
knocking down grandma's house
so we can cram two tall and skinnies on
that little lot so we all feel good what
have you been driving around nashville
i'm just there's something about
heritage man and um
just finding that balance that wisdom
balance yeah i'm with you
i agree this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free
stage chris and caitlin are with us hey
guys how are you
hey jerry great welcome welcome good to
have you guys where do you live
uh san antonio texas good and you're
here to do a debt-free scream how much
did you pay off
we paid off two hundred and thirty
thousand dollars
and you're how long did this take uh we
started um
february of 2015 and then we made our
last payment on christmas day of this
year
so six years six years
all right very good and your range of
income during that time
we started at 38 and then we ended at
150.
okay cool so with that length of time
and that large amount was that student
loans or did you pay off your mortgage
oh gosh it was majority student loans we
borrowed a lot
yes uh we actually looked at the
the student loans that's like a giant
credit card where we were just living
off of it
maxing out our loans and what referred
to the
reaping my fruit before we even planted
the seeds
what's your degrees in my degree is in
nuclear medicine
but currently i work for a tech
tech company okay and i am a physical
therapist assistant
very cool okay well two great career
fields but what did you pay dearly for
them
yes we do yeah so uh what what's your
household income now 50 150.
150. between the two of you okay and
probably on the way up right
oh yes yeah how old are you two i'm 33.
and i will be 38 later this year all
right and 230 000 cleared off in six
years so tell us the story what happened
um it all started um back in 2015.
my boss at the time shout out chad keck
hey um
he gifted all of his employees a uh the
financial piece book
and i read it and i thought wow
there's a plan for this it makes so much
sense
because we were at a point where we
borrowed so much we couldn't actually
borrow any more
chris was in school i had just gotten my
adult job
and i read the book and was like oh this
gives me every step
how to how to save how to start paying
my student loans it gave us a way out
and so after reading the book i brought
it to chris like chris
i think this is uh you've got to read
this please read this i've never had you
asked you to read a book before but
please read this book
anna well yeah i read it and
and uh immediately came to her like yeah
that makes sense let's let's do this
and and she's like okay one of the first
things i want to do is i want to cut the
cable off i'm like oh you want to do
what
and she's like yeah and i wanted did i
just sign up for exactly
and then she that she wanted to
move down an apartment we had a
two-bedroom really large apartment she's
like also want to move down i'm like
wait
what so i had to go back and re-read
your book i was like i missed something
apparently alone
when someone with a degree in nuclear
medicine says this is how it's going to
be
that's you just go yeah
but then uh once i read your book and uh
i caught that part of the gazelle
intensity
and um one of the first things i looked
at was the fact that i had this
brand this f-150 i've wanted since high
school
and um we were yeah we had uh we had
what you referred the the log jam
like how are we gonna break this up
because we had forty dollars a month
forty dollars left over at the end of
the month like how are we gonna do this
and i looked at my shiny truck and said
i'm gonna go sell that and my wife was
like
she's like well i didn't want to tell
you to do that but i'm so glad you want
to do that
like i can't force you to do it but man
i'm so glad you decided on your own
i took your house you're a real man now
that you decided that yeah
so i sold that truck and i got a little
three thousand dollar prius and then uh
signed up for a pizza delivery company
wow and uh i started delivering pizzas
to pay cash for my college for the rest
of the week wow what did you make a
month delivering pizzas
oh man uh i was pulling at least like a
hundred dollars a night every single
time doing that
especially whenever the spurs how many
nights a month um i was doing that
five days a week during that time so
you're making like two three thousand
dollars a month
just just off of that but that was all
going to make sure that we didn't take
any more students
i got that but i mean it's still that's
a lot of pizza money yes
very well done but i want to note that
because when you made this decision
you started working really hard and your
hard work was to keep you at
from not digging anymore you weren't
even going you weren't getting ahead at
this point
you worked this hard just to stay to
stay level
and finish school yeah between between
that
and the fact that i was in school with
this need for gazelle intensity at the
time it was equivalent of if the
cheetah got a head start and i'm just
raring back behind the gate waiting to
catch up and then as soon as i finished
school
i was working seven days a week three
different jobs wow
good for you man wow yeah and then six
years later you're done
six years later that's a long time yes
sir and caitlyn you know
when a texas guy sells his truck for a
prius that's he's all in
oh let me tell you he's all in
god even you're like i don't know honey
i was so proud of him though because
that that truck got nine miles to the
gallon i was like we can't even afford
the gas
that's that's impressive well when
you're willing to live like no one else
so that later you can live like no one
else it works
yes sir yeah it works now you're free
you're 30 years old and some change
and you got no debt at all and you make
100 and a half on your way to 200 and a
half
and you know oh my gosh you've got your
future
is multi-millionaires yes sir yeah it's
it's right there and i can see it i mean
i see the math i've watched it for 30
years
you're just gonna you're gonna do it i'm
so proud of y'all thank you very much
it's amazing i mean your hard work your
sacrifice okay we talked about several
things you
did on the journey is there anything you
want to add when i say
when people ask how did you do this what
do you tell them
definitely consistency and creating a
budget
i know a lot of people say you know
doing the budget was the thing but
we thought we were on a budget until we
actually did a budget together
because i was the one that mainly took
care of the finances and when i got him
involved we're like oh we're missing
some things we're not covering
everything
but once we got a budget we realized
what we could afford
to keep us out of debt and it kept us on
the same page and helped us communicate
more
it was just the whole journey was the
best marriage counseling we've ever done
since we never did it so i'm glad we
went through this so we're always on the
same page and have the same goals now
yeah i think for me it was the key is to
his belief
whether you're paying off debt you're
trying to lose weight or try to quit
smoking
if you don't believe that what you're
doing is is not working if you don't
believe
the process is working or if you don't
believe that the other side of all of
this is worth it
then you're not going to pursue it as
much without struggling there was times
where i was metaphorically crawling on
my hands and knees
because i was physically tired and
emotionally exhausted from working so
much
but it's knowing that this was a light
at the end of the tunnel i kept pushing
yeah wow very very you're right very
impressive
i mean people who if you want to uh
sacrifice or
or embrace pain with no potential
outcome that's just mental illness
yeah i mean yeah there has to be a
reason to do this there has to be a
light at the end of the tunnel it's not
an oncoming
a little bit in there in there yeah it's
just strange man so you guys know that's
very very very well done very well done
what was the hardest part for you
it was literally the day by day and
knowing it would take us so long when we
started we knew it'd be at least five
years and of course all the different
roadblocks that came you know with
medical bills
uh global pandemic oh there's that yeah
just a little bit
and then not to mention texas had a nice
little snowpocalypse that happened
recently oh yeah
oh yeah yeah we had that too um
definitely day by day just uh
being each other's cheerleader and
getting through um one of our biggest
goals is we want to get a house
yeah uh since we're in such a small
apartment and we knew if we don't do
this
it's not even a possibility yeah it's
not even going to happen well now you
can
sure we have more options now well done
we're so proud of you guys this is so
cool thank you so much they're amazing
yeah and your marriage come what may
come the house buy and come
kids come in-law challenges come out you
have it you have a
six-year chain that you all have built
that no
nothing's going to come your way you
can't figure out and sit down at a table
and work together because
that that same skill you learn budgeting
is how you're going to sit down and
approach hard conversations and
challenges and job layoffs and job
successes and hey we got to move
somewhere else and whatever that's
what's going on built into their brains
now that's right that's who you guys are
i'm so proud of you man
chris and katelyn san antonio 230
000 paid off in six years making 33 to
150
they did it hard work count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
all right everybody you might want to
turn your volume down a little bit
all right ready three two one we're
debt-free
[Applause]
wow unbelievable
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsey show dr john deloney is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
rachel's in green bay wisconsin hi
rachel how are you
good how are you guys doing better than
i deserve how can i help
so my husband and i recently bought our
first home and we're trying to figure
out how much is too much to spend on
some updates and purchases for the house
uh updates and oh you want to do some
renovation after you bought it
yes so we're looking to do some new
paint some carpet
we need a few appliances um because the
sellers are taking some of them
with them um and just kind of looking at
some big price tags and not wanting to
spend too much money
okay um
number one do you have the cash to do
whatever it is we're talking about no
debt
yes okay and do you have that above your
emergency fund
yes and you are debt-free except the
house
uh we actually don't have a mortgage
either oh
well that's nice so you pay cash for
this house
yes wow so what's the house what'd you
pay for it
uh we paid 290 for it good for you
how'd you do that um
our parents helped us out with about
half and then we are just the big big
savers who never liked it okay cool
so you have a 300 000 house that you
paid cash for
how old are you uh 24.
good god almighty you are a freak i love
you
you're amazing that's so cool so what
are you thinking about spending on these
renovations
um and totally probably about 25 000.
and you have the 25 000. yes do it yes
yesterday
you knew it you are not listen the two
of you
the way your brain and your relationship
is put together the chances of you
overspending or being impulsive on
something is almost zero
it's almost zero okay so okay
i would probably tell you to add to it
just because but i won't
just to have the enjoyment yes yes spend
30 000 okay
yeah yeah you guys are incredible
very well done what's your household
income
uh combined about 150. wow
what do y'all do for a living um i'm an
analytics and my husband's an engineer
so how did you learn that does that
these principles were important where'd
you learn all this from your mom and dad
or what
yeah my i remember my mom listening to
you in the car when i was in elementary
school
when she was uh picking me up from
school it's genetic for you at this
point right
right exactly and then you had a really
great guy
who was yeah just right on board right
at the start
so so that sounds like a joke like a an
analytics person an engineer walking to
a bar right what do you all do for fun
like you get a bottle of wine and some
spreadsheets and you're like this is
like
like what do you all do for fun
like i'm being i'm being serious yeah we
were recently married and um you know
we like to go take trips but
i haven't been able to do that too much
but i don't know we're just kind of
homebodies so
yeah good for you let me ask you
something what is this
what is the thing you're thinking about
buying for this house that you
really you you don't want to do it
because you think it's
over the top and crazy
um we'd like to get some really nice
patio set up outside yeah i think you
need to build a full-on outdoor kitchen
okay
absolutely and let's let him enjoy
what i'm doing okay there's three things
that you can do with money you can give
it
you can live it spend it in other words
and enjoy it
um or you can invest it you have no
trouble
saving and investing but it's go
it is a good exercise for you to also
learn to enjoy money
i very seldom have to have that
conversation on this show
most of the time i'm like quit spending
like you're in congress
but you need to loosen up and enjoy it
because you're
you're very disciplined you're very
intentional i'm so thankful your mama
made you listen when you're in
elementary school so you're financial
peace baby i'm glad that we're part of
your story of incredible success
but part of your success is generosity
and part of your success is enjoying the
money
as well as continuing to be very careful
very wise and very intentional
and it's hard to get off the rails with
a paid for house of 24.
paid for 300 000 yeah yeah i'm making a
hundred and a half
150 and and and and they're you know
that those career fields are both going
up
highly transferable field and they're
very go and they're going up from there
i mean they're going to make
in in two years would be a 200 easy
between the two of them so they're
they're gonna you guys are gonna be
multi-millionaires uh
and and your outdoor kitchen isn't gonna
mess that up it's gonna help your
homebodiness to have a cool outdoor
kitchen right i love this
that's it oh what a cool story zev's in
san francisco hi zev
hi dave um long time listener first time
caller
uh really it's an honor to speak with
you you too sir um the reason
thank you um the reason i'm calling was
because unfortunately my father died
about five months ago leaving me a house
in san francisco
yeah i'm sorry i left me a house in camp
thank you thank you
i appreciate that um but the the silver
lining i guess as it were is that he did
leave me a house in san francisco
and a pretty sizable estate he left me
about
a house worth about two million dollars
and an estate worth about
four million on top of that how old are
you um
i'm 32. okay are you married and
i'm not married okay nope all right
um and i came into this i was already
worth about three hundred thousand
dollars when this all happened
my annual income is around the forty
thousand dollar mark i actually am a law
school dropout i dropped out of law
school about five years ago to
caretake for my father and never went
back
so that's kind of the situation from a
like career standpoint i've been
teaching
in the meantime um middle
my question is the house is falling
apart but i'm very sentimentally
attached to it but i hate san francisco
and california
and i'm facing like a lot of repair
costs
and but i do have a very low tax rate
because of this thing called prop 13 in
california i'd say about a thousand
dollars a year
yeah my question is
do i take money from this estate and
just dump it into the house and fix it
up
or do i try to get over the sentimental
piece of this
and look at it more from a financial
perspective and just say you know what
this house is a money pit
and sell it and go live out of state uh
where i can
live the kind of life that i want for a
much lower cost of living that's
basically my question
i like the emotional simplicity of
selling it now and moving
okay the downside of that is that's
going to hurt because
of the freshness of
if your dad had passed two years ago it
would feel you will feel more released
than you do with him passing five months
ago does that make sense
yes yeah your sentimental value from
that for that house is going to go down
every day that you own it
um from today forward and so it's going
to be emotionally easier to let it go
a year from the day than it is today
but aside from you know your your
grieving
and your attachment to the house and
your memories
and all of those things um you also have
this other side that sees a fresh start
a clean whiteboard
and there's a lot of health in you
moving on john from a grief perspective
if he sells it
now and truncates some of that those
feelings does that is that a problem
no because every day you stay there is
going to be a penalty paid against the
memory of your father
and you already have part of your heart
as much as you love your dad that says i
gave up this
dream i gave up this world to love and
honor and take care of him
and continuing that way of of living
is gonna end up compressing this memory
of your dad
and so i'm going to tell you to sell a
house go be free selling this house is
in your future anyway sell your house
go start over clean that's the best way
to honor your father moving forward
and rehabbing that house is going to be
more emotional than
sitting in it for six months you're
going to sell it anyway so
i'll just sell it and move on i really
would and that has nothing to do with
financial that's just being
just opening the next chapter in the
book of your life
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones as we talk to
you about your life
and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five robert in brooklyn new
york starts us off this hour hey robert
how are you
good afternoon dave dr john how are you
guys great man
how can we help great great um
about a year ago my father passed away
uh he was my uh business partner we have
general contracting company
and uh and a very you know and obviously
my best friend as well
and uh we had two properties that we
invested in
uh recently that now i'm half partners
with
my mother by default and i wanted to see
what your guy's opinion on
uh what i should do with them
um i'm sorry for your loss mm-hmm
um thank you i appreciate it is there um
okay you and your dad work together
every day and so
you could fight things out you could
talk things out for the business or for
the
investments or anything else if you had
a renter problem you just talk it
through
how's it going with your mom
uh essentially i'm doing everything
which is fine she had no involvement
with the business so uh
i just since he passed away i've been
doing everything
do you want to still be in business
talk to john at the conversation for a
different time but that's
that's where i'm at right now i mean i
do i i do enjoy being a general
contractor
has its ups and downs but um are you
asking about the are you asking about
the
houses what to do with them or what are
what are we trying to get to here
yes the properties i'm trying to figure
out what i should do with them
okay all right well there's nothing
wrong with you managing them
and owning half with your mom as long as
there's not some kind of toxic
stuff going on it's not putting a strain
on anybody there's also nothing wrong
with you selling both of them and
splitting up the money
give her some money and you take some
money and you can even help her get with
an investment broker and do some
investing
um you know so she's got some of that
money coming in
uh what would she like to do
uh she she's left it in my hands um she
is
on board either way um my father and
mother they had a great
marriage but i never realized how little
she was involved in the finances
so since um his passing i've
basically had to give her a crash course
on on how everything gets paid for
you know and my the two properties we i
would say we invested about
i would say six to seven hundred
thousand they make about
90 gross a year and they're worth about
2 million if you sell them
so in that circle that loops me back to
my question
do you want to keep doing this um
because if your mom's indifferent
and the finances here if you sold these
properties and walked away with it with
a
the hefty return on this it sounds like
the real question for you is do you want
to
still keep being in this business you're
you're in it with your mom financially
but she's not help coach he's not trying
to
jump in and manage it and i think we
should do the lawn this way and i want
to use this roofer
and so really it comes down to you want
to do this or not there's nothing wrong
with either answer
no in terms of the financial or business
aspects of it
since there's no toxicity um it's i
i let me ask you something i think i'm
hearing
a little bit of resentment for her being
what we call in the south a kept
woman uh she was so taken care of and so
in the dark and she's just like you keep
doing all the work like your daddy did
and just send me the money
yes it's i mean not exactly in that
sentiment but yeah she's concerned about
me having to take on the burden of
supporting her because i gave her my
father's paycheck for the past year
and everything to kind of get everything
settled but i'm at the point where if i
continue the business
i need to free up that capital to hire
people to help me yeah you know
a very big spot business is a separate
equation from the real estate is it not
yes but they're it's their to me they're
intertwined because if i sell it i could
reinvest in my own business
so robert robert you still have avoided
my question
what do you want to do dr john what am i
what do i want to do
what do you want to do with the real
estate and then what do you want to do
with the business
i know you guys i want to keep the real
estate i want to sell
it done sell it split the money with her
help her do some investing help her go
through
i'll give you ramsey plus let's put her
through a money course so she learns how
to be a
a person who handles her own funds okay
we'll teach her how to handle money and
i'll pay for it
sure i'll take care of widows here
that's what we christians do
and so we'll do that we'll take care of
her in that regard not by taking care of
her but by showing her how to take care
of herself teaching her fish rather than
giving her fish
and then she's going to have a million
dollars and then you're gonna use some
of this money to buy
her out of your business aren't you
no no she has nothing in the business
it's not to buy her out okay so she
doesn't have any ownership of the
business from the estate
no sir okay sir okay cool sell the real
estate split the money help her get set
up and get running
and you use the money on your side to
run your business is that okay
sure yeah yes does that make you smile
it did yeah it did okay does your is
your dad is your dad in heaven smiling
uh i hope so yeah i think he is i think
i'm doing good you took care of your mom
and you're running your business
and you're a grown man you're going to
hand your mom a million dollars robert
you did a good job
you talked you sat down and taught your
mom how to take care of herself
you gave her a gift of freedom you're a
good son man you are you're a good man
um you're because listen a scumburger
wouldn't be wrestling with these things
no they would have sold the house and
given mom 50 000 and said look at all
this money
right and hey those are the kind of sons
that call my show sometimes dave
like they are out there robert and it's
not you yeah you're
a good man so hold on i'll have kelly
pick up and we'll get your mom signed up
for a year in ramsey plus she can go
through financial peace university she
can learn how to do a budget on every
dollar
there'll be coaches in there to help her
uh you can walk with her through the
whole process to ensure that she's
learning the lessons
there's accountability with groups and
coordinators in there it is
ramsey plus is the full package for you
to do the whole thing
and it's going to be free to her okay so
you hold on kelly will pick up
and we'll get that going there's nothing
wrong with starting ramsay plus with a
million dollars
head start right there's nothing wrong
with that at all sitting down with a
rent with a smartvestor pro and getting
that money invested what's the best way
we can do this that's right so
if you listen to the show
one of the reasons people listen to the
show is entertainment because
humans are just freaking entertaining
but the other thing you you
if my challenge to you guys listening is
to do what i've done for 30 years doing
the show and that is what is your take
away from some of these things so
here's your takeaway 45 year old couple
both of you need to know how to handle
money
because one of you is not going to be
here someday that's right
you are not empowered you are not
equipped
you cannot just say it's a famous
southern saying
whatever you wanna do honey no
because one day honey won't be there
you've got to learn how to do this
it is unfair to everyone in the picture
for you to intentionally not know how to
do this stuff and someone else take care
of you
you're a grown up fussing it mama
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
about 40 million americans filed for
unemployment benefits in 2020 congress
just passed a new
coveted relief plan that changed the
unemployment
tax rules here's the change your first
10 200 of unemployment benefits are free
from federal
taxes do not claim them as income other
unemployment benefits are taxable
there's a couple of cases where your
unemployment will be taxed
if you made over 150 000 total or if you
receive more than 10
200 in unemployment you will have to
claim your unemployment benefits as
income in either of those cases if you
want to make sure you're filing your
taxes right
we've got the help you need you can do
them online with the ramsey smart tax
software for just a few dollars or if
they're looking a little complicated
we'll connect you with a pro
that you can feel good about text the
word tax to 33 789
text tax to 33789
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today allison
is in cincinnati hi allison welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi dave and john how are you guys better
than i deserve how can we help
great well um thank you for taking my
call my husband and i have been avid
listeners since 2007
and we paid off all our debt back in
2012. wow and so
yeah so by listening to you guys all
those years my husband was actually able
to start a business in
2016 and he does remodeling and some
landscaping
primarily his work though is remodeling
he does have a
great customer base but the problem we
are running into
is he's a one-man show and he's
he's bombarded with work um and so much
that he
he can't keep up so it's a good problem
to have
but but now i think we're it's at the
point where we need to
um you know hire some people and so i
have some reservations though regarding
hiring people though because you know i
don't
the like the payroll withholdings um
finding trustworthy people that do
quality work
and then of course being able to pay
them absolutely we're still
trying to perfect the bidding process
getting jobs accordingly
um so we've tossed around the idea of
actually like 10 99 people
um that way they would handle their own
taxes and that kind of thing
but you know we're really stuck on what
to do and i hear you talk about your
contractor friend all the time and
how much money he actually makes just
being a handyman so
i'm just calling to get some guidance
and define um what would be the best way
to approach
this problem well you guys are
incredible well done
well thought out you you've accurate
accurately
identified some of the minds in the mine
field that you've got to miss
that you got you have to walk around to
have the opportunity to grow the
business
um but all of the things are that none
of those are insurmountable they can all
be handled
um but it's like anything you do the
first time is scary
and you'll be better at it the second
time than you were the first time
so uh you want to learn enough about
that you don't do harm to yourself or
someone else
but also cut yourself some slack because
uh i've been hiring people to work on
our team now
for over 25 years and i'm just now
getting good at it
i don't do it anymore but i mean you see
what i'm saying the first time i hired
somebody i was stupid i was dumb i
thought if you just hired somebody they
would work
allison even i got in the building man
he's not that great at it
so um here's the
upside and the reason you do need to do
this you need to face your fears and
walk through this
because right now your husband is a
wonderful contractor
he's a hard-working guy uh he owns his
job he doesn't yet own a business
when you're a one-man band and you're
sick
zero money comes in
when you go on vacation zero money comes
in
because there's no one else doing the
work carrying the water but
you and so you own your job and so
it is going to stabilize your life to
have at least
a little bit of growth to go to the one
to five employee range
is going to change your life in good
ways
a you'll be able to make more money b
you'll be able to get more work done
help more people
see when you're on vacation they're all
still working
if you hired well and led them well
okay so it stabilizes your life and
increases your income if you do this
properly
but it is a challenge to get good people
and it is a challenge to keep good
people
and uh doing the paperwork for the
stinking payrolls a pain in the butt
um but you can have a little company do
that for you get in touch with one of
our tax elps a lot of those have
bookkeeping services
and they can run your payroll for you
there's other places you can outsource
it's a little difficult to outsource one
or two people on a payroll to a payroll
company
but you can do it it's just you know
it's it's it's not that hard to do it
yourself
but i wouldn't recommend doing it i'd
recommend you out you have an accountant
do it for you or
a bookkeeper or some kind do it for you
as far as the hiring process goes
your husband has to add some skills uh
to his tool belt no pun
intended he currently is a great
contractor
he's good with customers he's good with
getting the actual work done he's handy
uh all of those things now he has to
start to learn how to lead
and hire right and fire and confront bad
behavior
and those kinds of things and so that's
a that's a whole other skill set that's
called leadership and call running a
business
and uh but it's a wonderful journey i've
been on that journey myself for 25 years
i am getting better at it all joking
aside
but i haven't arrived i still am
learning things every day i still make
mistakes every day as a leader
but uh but you you get a lot better at
it and you can build your competence and
your confidence just like he does
swinging a hammer
the same thing right and as far as the
money part goes
as far as the money part goes you hire
people that can make you more than they
cost you you cannot do the 1099 idea
uh it's uh i'm
probably it's not proper to say it this
way but it's against the law it doesn't
work
okay the law says that if someone acts
like an employee
walks like an employee talks like an
employee they're an employee even if you
declare them to be 10.99
1099 is an independent subcontractor
they run their own business
they don't work exclusively for you you
don't furnish them materials
you don't furnish them jobs and you
don't furnish them hammers
and saws and you're doing all of that
what you have is not 10.99 you have an
employee and if you get audited with a
1099 on there and it's supposed to have
been an employee
you're going to get penalized okay
that's good you know what what would you
think would be a
like what's the i guess formula
how much should you have in reserves to
be at the point where
you know how much do you have no you
have enough how much do you have in
reserve
um we have probably
like 25 000 right now in reserve you're
fine
okay you're fine for two hires because
you're going to hire people that are
going to make what kind of money
um i don't know we haven't really
discussed that
i mean yeah they're not going to make
160 000.
they're going to make they're going to
make 30 000 bucks right
or 40 000 bucks
right i mean something like that so you
know you've got enough to cover
easily three months of them producing
absolutely no income
and they're only a cost and so you could
start talking about putting the first
two on
but lay out your game plan to go okay
i'm gonna be able to get
this much more income in as if i'm gonna
spend
three thousand dollars a month on this
guy i'm gonna make six thousand dollars
a month on this guy
so he's not only free he puts money in
my pocket
you have to have you have to make more
on them than they cost you
or your your formula for hiring people
makes you go broke
okay so then when he bid he should he
should bid for
two guys versus one guy bids
when he did the job no he needs to bid
the job
if it takes two guys to do the job you
do that
but i'm just saying in other words your
husband's doing job a
right now job b he can't do the new hire
is going to go to
job b so you're going to get the profits
from job b
over and above what you paid the new guy
okay and so you paid the new guy out of
job b the extra work
and you're going to make a profit on job
b that you wouldn't have gotten because
you couldn't have done it because your
husband's on job a
right just dividing and conquering
basically doing double the work
yeah yeah you got to increase the work
level increase the revenues as a result
of having more workers
that's what i mean by they're paying for
themselves and it's recognizing it's a
different job than the trade
you've got it you've got to be as good
as a leader and a higher and a fire in
the bookkeeper
you've got to put that much effort as
you did and to learn how to work that
circular saw right yeah both of you do
yeah yeah and this is where people going
from
to their first team members really
really struggle you really have to start
studying leadership it's a craft
hold on i'm going to send you a copy of
our book entree leadership and get you
started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage krista is with us hi krista
how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve where do you live
uh near toledo ohio near where do you
live uh genoa ohio
okay all right because i went to ice
hockey camp in bowling green when i was
a kid just south of toledo there
close by right in your area cool so how
much debt have you paid off
90 858 dollars and two cents
love it how long did this take 23 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time uh 62 to 75
000 cool what do you do for a living i
teach agriculture to 7th through 12th
grade students
oh wow good for you thank you so what
kind of debt was the 91 000 uh
80 000 was student loans from ohio state
university and my master's degree at
capell university out of minnesota
and then about 10 000 car loan okay
wow so how long have you been out of
school
oh gosh um graduated in 2012.
eight years okay yes whatever yeah and
getting ready to be nine
and the 80 000 is just hanging out huh
yup yeah well i decided to go back to
get my master's degree so i've now had
that for about two and a half years
yeah but the rest of us just been
hanging out just sallie mae had our own
bedroom
so what happened 23 months ago lit you
up
uh well actually my brother and my
parents have been through financial
peace university and they um
my actually my brother for christmas got
me the book in 2017. i waited till a
year later to find my first
class because like most people you're
not sure
um to believe it or not so i waited for
a year later
your brother joined a cult
[Laughter]
so found a class and then i actually in
2019
went through that and then in 2020 i
went through the a second class just
to keep me fresh and understanding what
i'm doing as well
yeah while you were on the journey yeah
it's a good encouragement to loop back
through or to coordinate a class
sometimes people do that
yeah well done okay so what happened
when you went in there that
made you say i can do this
uh just me going after goals and um
just wanting to pay off that debt
because i don't want to have debt
i want to be able to go and live and go
on vacations and
get sallie mae out of the house yeah
absolutely how does it feel
it feels great was it worth the
sacrifice it sure was and i still
continue to sacrifice things but you
still can save money in different ways
and still not have debt what was your
biggest
hardest sacrifice during that 23 months
i'm telling people no that i can't go
out to eat i only have 85
a month for my budget when the money's
gone it's gone yeah yeah
okay that because that's a social
experiment mm-hmm
yeah did you have a group of people that
hung with you
and said all right we'll all come over
then um
i mean my parents we just all hung out
so you got a lot of family support all
the way through that's good
that's good what was it like walking
with
middle and high school students while
you're walking through this
did they did you did they know you're
doing this so i did tell a lot of my
students
they actually teach fpu at my high
school
so they don't believe it so i can't wait
till i go back in my agriculture classes
they're going to all see this
you're a youtube star now yeah i love it
[Laughter]
well congratulations thank you we're
very very proud of you
so uh when you teach foundations for
personal finance to high schoolers in a
future
class which you may end up doing i i bet
uh what are you going to tell them the
secret to getting out of debt is
um staying on a budget and being
persistent
23 months 23 months changes everything
yep
and i definitely went into my savings um
i first did the ten thousand dollars
and that was still there did the next
ten thousand
still was there and then i did the next
so i taken
thirty thousand dollars out of my
savings to put towards that
wow and then punched it in the nose also
over the 23 months
yeah good for you that's scary to do
it was at first and the debt was still
there yeah
doesn't go away nope doesn't go away do
you pay it i love it
i'm so proud of you and it's cool for
these students to see
that you're not a theory you're not a
good idea you're walking talking
living proof of what happens when you
work really hard
for these kids that are going to go into
agriculture right that plant seeds for
today so that something will grow for
tomorrow
you're you're a teacher that's walking
the walk and and that
that multiplies your your effect on
those young people you're changing a
bunch of
family trees with the sacrifices you
made good for you thank you
and i know it's hard if your brother's
worth his salt he's going to rub your
nose in this a little bit so good for he
came with her
is he when i'm out here yeah mom and dad
are here too right
so you got the cheering squad here
that's great i love it and a little bit
if i told you so right
why you do it sooner yeah i'm so proud
of you
well done i know they are proud of you
excellent job we got a copy of rachel
cruz's
latest new york times bestseller know
yourself know your money thank you and
uh
we'll come out and sign that and
everything at the break here so so very
proud of you
all right it's krista from the toledo
ohio area 91
000 paid off in 23 months making 62-75
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
i love it so
fun so fun the number of people now i
mean financial peace
foundations and personal finance now
taught in 48 percent of high schools
in north america and the number of
people that have gone through financial
peace university and ramsey plus now
got a ramsey plus membership um
you know get connected to every dollar
get on the budgeting app
it enables you to do the stuff that
these folks are doing that are doing
these debt-free screams and so
you know it's you you need the
information
and the inspiration to do one of the
hardest things you're ever going to do
in your life but one of the most
rewarding things you're ever going to do
in your life and that is
get yourself positioned to become
wealthy
you get positioned to do that most
likely
by being clear of debt so ramsey a
ramsey plus
membership will do all of that for you
you plan out every dollar you connect
your budget to your bank you get custom
budget reports
you get everything you need there's a
free trial for ramsey plus
a free trial at daveramsey.com
just go to daveramsey.com and look for
the free trial on mc plus you get you
get started on the whole thing
you'll see how it all works we'll walk
you through every bit of it
and you'll have you know that's the
almost every one of these people do that
free screams have been through
financial peace absolutely and they've
they've either taught it or they've
talked about the accountability of the
other folks in that group saying hey
we're doing it too we're doing it too
and
everybody i know who has a budget has
that month or those two months when they
think man
everybody who works out it's like i'm
not doing it everybody who fill in the
blank and having a group of people with
you get that information inspiration
you get that community around you that
that just
is that prodding or that holds your arms
up in the desert man you gotta you gotta
have some cheerleaders
you can't just have people trying to
drag you down that's you gotta have i
mean there's lots of people tell you you
can't win
that's that's the culture we live in
yeah is they don't want you to win
because it makes them look bad
i call it the titanic syndrome when that
movie came out it was every everybody
loved it until everybody loved it and
then it became cool to talk about how
dumb that movie was and
it just came to beat it up right it's
cool to look at somebody's going after
something and then think why are you
doing that that's stupid that's dumb
man and getting a group of people behind
you whether you're going for a run
whether you're getting a debt whatever
that is that is everything dave
it's everything they did that with disco
too
did they well this goes terrible no it
was cool
it was cool until until some rocker
decided it wasn't cool and then it
wasn't cool anymore it's the same thing
there's a whole movement it's on you
ought to watch the uh the bg's uh
documentary it's a great documentary
so then it's like they they made so
stinking much money and then all of a
sudden
it's gone they went from being gods to
being
like a symbol of foolishness or
something you know it's the same kind of
thing though it was cool until it wasn't
cool
speaking of symbols i don't want to take
away from how extraordinary that jeffrey
scream was but you mentioned something i
never heard before
i just need a little bit more clarity on
you went to hockey camp
what is that what in the world
is ice hockey camp so much stories so
many stories and so little time coming
up on a commercial break
oh i see what you're doing here james
cue the music redneck redneck southern
hockey players can you imagine what this
was oh it was a fight and a hockey game
broke out
okay it's rare that my mind is blown and
dave i think he blew it
i played all the way up into college i
had no idea i don't know these things
i have antique um ice skates sitting in
my bookshelves in my
in my study at home they truly are
antiques
no question they're funny it's great
looks like something you got at a flea
market
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ramsay show dr john
deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today we're glad you're here
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five
two two five joshua is with us joshua is
in fredericksburg
virginia how are you joshua hey dave i'm
doing great how you doing
better than i deserve how can i help
so i just have a quick question um i'm
relatively new to your show but i've
been watching a lot of clips and uh
i'm on my way i'm on baby step number
one getting my money put away in savings
um i want to ask a question about when
i'm moving full force onto step two
i want to ask your advice on i have the
opportunity
to act as a private auction so i can
flip a few cars a year
um and i wanted to know uh if you agree
with stuff like
you know spend money to make money type
side gigs where i
can buy cars and flip them in the
process of paying off debt
to you know help me get more profits
overall and pay things off quicker
are you doing that with cash
yeah well so instead of just putting it
full force on the debt i would put cash
aside to
buy cars on the cheap and then flip them
when you buy the car you're paying cash
for the car
yeah that's what i mean okay so give me
an example
you would buy a car you buy a car for
how much and flip it for how much
so i could probably get a car for two
grand and easily flip it for four
to five um because like i said i have
private i have access to a private
auction so the cars are a lot cheaper
than
anyone you know a public auction or
anywhere else
okay and um and what do you make of
your day job about 33 grand i just
started up a new job
okay all right and how much debt do you
have
so i have around 14k in debt okay
i would do that now here's let's think
let's think through some guidelines
because as you know you can get sucked
into this
um and i you know you can start
you can put all the money back in and
all this kind of stuff and then you
then you ended up benefiting your debt
payoff not at all
but you sure did get into a bunch of
cars okay so we don't want to do that
so it's one at a time and
you take you know you say i'm gonna okay
i'm gonna put some
seed money in or prime the pump if you
will and so we're gonna set two thousand
bucks in
and then you buy that car and you flip
it for
thirty five hundred and you pull the
2000 out to do the next deal
keeping it there but the anything above
the 2000 goes on the debt
every single time everything above the
2000 goes down to the debt
okay don't buy a 2200 car or a 3 000
car the next time you're buying a 2 000
car
every time or whatever your ba your your
baseline is
but you what can happen is emotionally
you get more caught up in doing the
deals
than you do actually causing the deals
to benefit you
and you go well you know i i you know if
gosh if i turn to 2000 into three i
could turn a three into six
and then i could turn a four into eight
and then you get sucked into this vortex
and all the money's pouring back into
this system you're building
rather than in getting out of debt does
that make sense
yeah yeah absolutely i get you i didn't
even think about that and knowing me
i would fall into that for sure well
you're a player that's how i know to get
warn you against that because i'm a
player it's the kind of thing i do
and so i have to watch against it and
car auction directors
love players because they say man if you
just go to five on this you can you can
flip this for 14.3 easy
and it's just hard hard you have to be
disciplined right yeah
you really have to be disciplined that's
the purpose of an auction is to take
advantage of undisciplined people
or to pit disciplined people undispute
people against each other
yeah exactly and then you get then all
of a sudden there's no room in the deal
because you've overpaid that's what you
get into but yeah give yourself some
real strict
business operational guidelines if you
will like i just laid out
something like i laid out and then every
time stick to them don't let your
uh don't don't let the uh uh the greed
on one shoulder talk you again to losing
your common sense on the other shoulder
and if there's no two thousand dollar
deals to be had this particular saturday
go home you
walk away go home you'll walk away
that's exactly right that is a good plan
rob is with us in tampa florida hey rob
welcome
to the ramsey show hey dave how you
doing thanks for taking my call
my pleasure how can we help uh
so i have this out-of-state property
that i want to
get rid of it's a a rental property
and i don't know whether or not i would
like your advice on
either paying the capital gains or
taking a 1031.
i had my tax guy kind of look at it and
he estimated something about
uh 75 000 in the capital gains
so you got like a half million dollar
gain
i yeah i think where i'm trying to sell
this out-of-state property
so you've got you've had it a while and
the uh what's it sell for
i'm asking for upwards of over 800.
yeah okay and you've adjusted the basis
down by
depreciating it over the years you're
having a lower adjusted basis am i right
i bought uh yeah i i
bought it 10 years ago yeah and you've
been depreciating it on your taxes
yes sir yeah and every time you do that
that amount of depreciation comes off
your basis and increases your gain you
understand that right
yeah yeah okay all right that's what i'm
talking about adjusted basis all right
so uh a 1031 tax deferred
exchange will probably cost you 1500 to
2 000
in legal fees to execute you have to
have an irs approved closing company to
do it in
you can sell the property into an escrow
account
with one of those companies and then you
have so many days i believe it's 60 days
to identify
and six months to close on the other
property
and that affects effectually creates a
trade
and you've rolled all of your equity and
your basis
over to the other property someday
uh if you ever sell that property you're
going to pay
even more capital gains because you will
have lowered the basis even more at that
point
so okay uh do you want rental property
in your area
uh if i can give you like a just a brief
history so
um i didn't expect to become an out of
state landlord
uh i always thought i was gonna move
back into that house but i like where
i'm at
now i wouldn't mind having
rental property here but that house was
really my house that i wanted to live in
it's gone well it's gone so
you know do you want this money to
invest in mutual funds
minus 75 000 or do you want to own
rental property
in your area i think i wanted i was
wondering if i could move back into it
after
1031 exchange and i'd be my house again
no if you sell the house you don't own
it anymore
no i know so my question was i'm sorry
whether or not to go ahead and just pay
the capital gains tax
buy myself own house we'll kind of do a
1031.
you can't do a 1031 to your personal
residence
it has to be to another rental property
okay so do you own a property in tampa
that you live in
no i'm renting right now okay so you
want to use this money to buy a house
with to live in
yes okay you cannot do that with a 1031.
1031 is a like-kind exchange and it
requires you go from rental to rental i
didn't know that either
not your personal residence you can't
pour it into your personal residence
and you can't sell your personal resume
maybe so pay the 75 000
in taxes take the gain out and buy you a
nice house in tampa rob that's the
answer
sounds good you don't have you don't
have any other options really
that that is your best choice at this
stage of the game
1031's about moving investments around
so you can do with a ranch or with a
with a farm as long as it's income
producing
okay yeah like i had a friend that had a
lake house but he never rented it out
so it never produced any income and he
sold it
and we were going to try to do a 1031
for him to get another lake house
from lake house to lake house and i'm
claiming that's like kind and the tax
guy looked at me cross-eyed like i was
an idiot
because i was an idiot and he said you
know no you can't do that because it
never
produced income if he'd been renting it
out occasionally as a resort rental or a
b b
or you know vrbo or something he
probably could have
done it to the moved it to the a
different lake house but lake house to
lake house doesn't work
and i ran into that a few years ago on a
transaction i was
helping a neighbor with but uh so what's
the government's
what is their long-term play you know
we'll do this another time
why they even would allow a 1031
exchange well they used to allow trade
you could trade properties and not have
to pay the capital gain
that was all okay so this this is
effectively a trade
okay but those guys at some point
they're going to get it at some point
unless you die and then they're stepped
up basis when you don't
okay lots of crap that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice i am dave ramsey your
host thank you for joining us america
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
my co-host today dr john deloney ramsey
personality
best-selling author and also the host of
the dr john delony show
an explodingly popular podcast by the
ramsey network
everything going up on that so be sure
you check out dr john dolone's
podcast uh everyone else in america is
if you haven't checked it you're one of
the few
so be sure and do that and you can
participate in that show and call in on
it uh you can
send an email in kelly will set you up
to be a caller
whatever you want to do he takes calls
and gets into people's
situations with their relationships
anything you can imagine education
school and marriages and breakups and
relationships and mental health issues
and anything having to do with
mental health and anxiety and boundaries
and all that
yeah yeah and we get into everything and
we'll take those calls here today too
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two five
asheville north carolina michael starts
this hour hey michael what's up
hey dave how are you i've got my
nine-year-old daughter with me here
hi hi we are very excited to be on your
show thank you for taking our call
well we're honored to have you here john
dr john i gotta say i love your show
whenever i'm having a bad day i
i just listen to that it makes me
realize my life is so much better than
some other calling that you get
i thought you were gonna say your life's
better than mine and i was gonna agree
with you but i appreciate you
[Laughter]
so um i had a quick question about 529
plans
my wife and i are debt-free as of last
year we just started a 15-year mortgage
incomes around 115 looking to be at
about 1 30 here later in the year
and we have about 225 in retirement um
i've been going back and forth with my
um
uh my investor um i was telling him we
were going to take your suggestion and
put about 15
into retirement um and he says because
we're behind he was hoping we could do a
little bit more i know that's his job to
do that
um i was toying with anywhere between
five and six hundred dollars
for a 529 split between a eight and a
ten-year-old
um and i just wanted your advice on what
you would do if you were in my situation
an eight or a ten year what i i have two
kids one is oh an eight and a ten year
old
oh okay yeah okay all right
um well if you get with one of our smart
investor pros
uh to get a second opinion they will
have you put 15
into retirement and you can run a
calculation out as to how much
you need to put for each child to be
able to hit
the goal by the time they're 18 and have
their the
vast majority or whatever portion you
say you know i want to have x
number of dollars in that college fund
by 18
then you can back that in at current
rates of return on mutual funds
with a smartvestor pro and they can show
you exactly what you need to put in
there
um what you're proposing is not bad at
all
that's wonderful i mean that's six
thousand dollars a year you're putting
in
500 bucks a month uh obviously the older
one would get a little more than the
younger one
because you've got a shorter time frame
to get to a college fund
and so you know it doesn't have to be a
lot more because they're fairly close in
age but
um but you know if you're gonna do are
you gonna do 500 total of 500
each uh so the number is closer to about
600 i was thinking putting a little bit
more in for the
um the older one and a little less for
the younger one yeah that's exactly what
i do
yeah and um
you know i would do that and i would be
putting 15 of your income into
retirement and above that
anything else you can find i'm gonna put
on the house let's get that house paid
off
and um uh so and again if you want a
second opinion
just click smart vester at
daveramsey.com and you can get with one
of the smart vista pros
the thing about the smartvestor pros is
they're going to always give you
uh advices that's congruent with what
you hear on this show
it's not going to be you're getting one
set of advice from me one set of advice
from them and then you don't know what
to do
right it should be anyway we're very we
spend a lot of time
a lot of effort with them uh making sure
they have the heart of a teacher
and that they know what we teach here so
that you go to them and you get
you know you got i want to do this
ramsey plan okay the baby steps here's
exactly what we're doing and then you
don't have this push and pull
well i wish you'd do more than that you
don't have that kind of stuff coming out
whenever i in the past when i've sat
down with a with the financial advisor
and they've
when they say this phrase so let's what
are your goals
i always feel like i'm at a car
dealership and they're saying
what's your what's your what can your
payment be right and there's something
about
i like going in saying um we're gonna do
15
of what you got right and then we're
going to talk about where would you like
to be and where's the how can we fill
that gap but there's something
that just feels oogy when somebody
starts with how much can i get you for
versus hey let me let me teach you how
this whole process works
exactly that's good i like that terry's
in tri-cities washington hi
terry how are you hi dave thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up um i
i want to know if i should start paying
down
my home i'm debt-free
except for my mortgage and
um but the
glitch is my house is a manufactured
home
but it's in a wonderful neighborhood in
a great location on a cul-de-sac without
any backyard neighbors
and i i really wanted to get into a
stick home and i
thought about it multiple times but i
thought
gosh i'd end up paying two to four
hundred dollars more a month on that
and right now i have seven to eight
thousand dollars in emergency fund
and um you know i make about 60 000 a
year so i'm
but am i and i paid for my house by
sometimes sometimes the answer to a
financial question
is very easy if you pay if you pan out a
little bit
and say 15 years from today
what is this going to end me with and so
if you stay in this home
15 years from today you're going to have
a mobile home that is worth almost
nothing
because they will fully go down in value
agreed
yeah yeah that's not good that's not
good
um and 15 years from today if you pay a
little more for a stick build home
you're gonna have something that's gone
up three or four
x in value
and the comps on my house are now 245
000
five years later so i thought well maybe
i should
take advantage of that yep yes because
it's not your house it's not your house
it's your lot
right well yeah the dirt is what's
valuable it is not the mobile home
100 of mobile homes go down in value
uh-huh i'm going to inherit my mom's
house hopefully later than sooner
but and and i'm 61 right now so
that was my other side if you want to
sit on that until that happens that's
okay
but you've got you know every day you
own a mobile home it goes down in value
and that's what you have so don't put
more money into my mortgage is about 840
a month
it doesn't matter if you want to pay it
off that's okay it's still going to go
down in value
right nothing wrong with getting rid of
the debt on it but it's still going to
go down in value matter of fact i
probably would get it paid off
make it easier to sell we sell the lot
in the mobile home together and
you know if you don't have a lien
against it'll probably make the whole
process easier
so that's not a bad thing but don't hold
this thing for 10 years
it's going down in value
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost sharing ministry
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at 825-5225
about 40 million americans filed for
unemployment benefits in 2020 congress
passed a new coveted relief plan
that changed the unemployment
tax laws if you took unemployment
your first 10 200 of unemployment
benefits are
tax free from federal taxes don't claim
them as income
however there's a couple of cases where
your unemployment will be taxed
if you went on during the year to make
over 150 000 and took unemployment at
any point you'll be taxed
on all of it or if you receive more than
10
200 in unemployment benefits you'll have
to pay taxes on the amount
over that couple of cases so check that
out
if you want to make sure you're filing
the right taxes the right way we've got
the help you need do them online with
ramsey smart
tax software very inexpensive just a few
dollars it's really
easy if you've got an uncomplicated
return if you do have a complicated
situation get with a pro
either way we can help you out text tax
to 33 789 text tax
to 33789
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping
or the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more always use the
promo code the magic word
ramsay all right today's question comes
from
jessica in washington state jessica
writes i'm a full-time mom with three
children
my husband's job allows no time for him
to finish
allows no time for him to give me a
break i'm one class away from a master's
degree and i can't even find time to
finish
we cannot afford child care how can i
find fulfillment and avoid becoming
bitter this sounds like a multi
there's a lot in this question dave
mm-hmm
um i've been through seasons where
obviously my wife's and i both had
graduate degrees we had a young kid we
were trying to finish those and racing
get done
and there was times we had to trade
certain things for child care we had to
get really creative with having somebody
come over and help out or folks from
where we worked or folks from school um
folks from church but
when we had to figure it out we figured
it out and unless somebody's out they
may be out on an island here so i don't
want to doubt jessica has gone to what
she can
gone to the ends to figure it out but it
sounds like she's got a challenge with
her husband's job
which below that is she's got a
challenge with her husband that's what i
heard yeah
um because listen i
we've been through seasons here when i
started this business i was working
16 hours a day right sharon will tell
you she was like a single mom
and uh and when i think about that
situation if we had sat down with three
kids and she's at home full-time
and i'm gone all the time i mean i was
teaching financial peace i'm on the
radio i'm traveling i'm speaking i'm
you know launching books i mean it was
about a two-year period of time
that i was leave before dark and come
home after dark i mean it was just
yeah i was working to get a business off
the ground and we were in agreement on
that
she was not embittered by that but if in
that setting
as hard as i was turning it on if she
had said i'm
one class from a master's degree
this is pissing me off i want to finish
it
we would have figured figured out a way
to adjust old dave's
that's right uh schedule uh
because i love my wife and and that is a
i mean if you want to go to back to
school for four years that's a different
equation you're
one class that's why it's something else
and you can't smell it you can't he
can't figure out a way to adjust his job
on that ever in the foreseeable future
i call bs i call well and the other side
of it is how can you find
fulfillment and avoid becoming better
you can't be fulfilled if you're in a
one-sided relationship
where somebody is not willing to sit
down and have this conversation with you
well i'm not sure their master's degree
makes you fulfilled i'm not sure even
getting a master's degree and going into
a career is going to make the
relationship issue here but this is
um uh it's not i don't know if i i'll
just take fulfillment out of it i'll
just be bitter
i mean come on bubba figure this out man
that's uh that's a husband problem
that's that's what old dave's reading
into that i'm not sure
it well it yeah just jessica's it's
do you find this that people like to
blame the job
and not the the employer employee
there's been seasons where i think it
was easier for me to get frustrated with
my wife's employer or her to get in
frustrated with my wife's employ
with my employer than to sit down and
say
hey john you're choosing work over us
yeah
yeah i mean it's yeah i mean if you
because here's the thing um
if he is in a good career in a positive
situation
he's getting a ton of attaboys and
affirmations
and he wants to stay there and get more
of those instead of come home
with somebody who's bitter and
unfulfilled
and exhausted from watching three kids
all day yeah but i mean yeah
he's like a hero there when he comes
home he's a dog so i mean i
i don't know i'm not blaming her either
i'm just saying uh or
you know he's just self-centered jerk i
don't know i don't know what's going on
what i can tell you is bitterness is the
the the paved road to resentment and you
don't come back from resentment
so this couple needs to throw a flag
turn all the lights on in the house and
say we got to stop this right now i
agree
i agree yeah and i i mean it might be
because here's the thing too maybe
there's he's in a situation where
for the next 12 months he's gonna have
to do this and it's all seasonal right
yeah but but when it's this all feels
like it's fatalistic it's forever
right and uh and that's what our that's
what it's
setting our both of our signals off yeah
we got flares going off all around our
brains right now
but the uh uh but if you go well for the
next 12 months
he's gonna have to turn it on but then
i'll be able to take my class
then you cannot be better because you
can see your your chance of finishing
this up
and that's a reasonable ask but that's a
couple coming together like a budget
right and saying it's going to take us
this much a month yeah to pay this off
in this but there's an
end to it that's right because you know
but but if this is like for the next 10
years it's just his job i just have to
put up with it
that's that's so fatalistic right that's
just that's the wrong way to look at it
there's
because nothing is that solid nothing
stays in place that long
andrea is with us in grand junction
colorado hey andrea how are you
good how are you great how can we help
so i have a question about um a home
that my husband and i bought last july
um the home was really old and we
planned to remodel it and
we before we bought it we got people in
to let us know about how much we were
looking at as far as
with everything we wanted to do we've
gone through phase one phase two of our
remodel now we're looking at phase three
which is a master suite edition
and from last summer to right now what
it cost to do that
that edition we went from about forty
thousand dollar
addition to now it's looking about 65 to
70.
uh my question is thank you
we did not change the plan it seems like
i don't know if it's just
number number prices are way up lumber
prices
lumber and steel yeah lumber and steel
both
have you got steel in the addition in a
residential
head on for a bedroom so it would be
digging out of a basement so that went
up substantially and then the lumber
digging out the bike i don't know
digging out the basement did not go up
if you got steel
i-beams across the basement to put the
dead gum bedroom on top of that went up
right that portion went up it seems like
the lumber went up and then we did a
metal roof and that also went off yeah
yeah um if we're you know to finish that
that part of it out yeah so my question
well i would put this project on home
bedroom would you okay yeah
because this is this is going to even
out because the lumber factories and the
steel factories both i don't know if
they're going to come
down dramatically but they are there's
just this tremendous shortage
because they weren't operating during
covid and and everybody was still
ordering lumber
and so there's this this drastic
shortage and that's
one of the things that's driving the
prices up i don't know that they'll come
back
down dramatically but they're i mean
they went up they went up 30 percent in
some cases lumber packages
that's somebody come quote me on some
new windows a few weeks ago then i got a
text yesterday that said hey we just
went up again i'll hold your price but
i mean it's it's it's everything yeah
yeah so
i i you know it might be that this
addition is now unrealistic that's my
point but
i would sit on it a little bit let some
of this go by if i were you
this is the ramsey shadow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
thank you
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage aaron is with us hey
aaron how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve sir where do you live i live in
pittsburgh pennsylvania cool welcome to
nashville and all the way down here to
do a debt-free scream yes sir how much
did you pay off sir i paid off 19 000
good for you and how long did this take
that took six months good for you
and your range of income during that
time uh 32 000. wow what do you do for a
living
uh i'm a graduate student researcher at
the university
okay yep what are you studying what are
you researching uh mechanical
engineering
outstanding good for you so how do you
do nineteen thousand to six months if
you
only make 32 how'd that work just
cutting the 19 000 in six months
uh no well i i was a really good saver
back in
back in the school so whatever oh yeah
so how much did you pull from savings
uh like i had like between like five and
six thousand dollars so i was
i was pretty good at saving beforehand
uh for you yeah but it was more so
uh just trying to get that into place so
what uh what fired you up what made you
decide uh six months ago you're going to
get after
it um so it was uh it was a march
whenever
the pandemic was uh starting and um
and uh uh like you know the whole world
was like on fire like
toilet paper is flying off the shelves
like it seemed like the
world was coming to the end and then
they were talking about uh forbearance
uh with student loans and i realized
that like i had no idea how much
like i owed and i was like okay well i
need to
figure out how to get on a budget and
stuff so i went on youtube
figured out how to make a budget like it
was like some college professor on
youtube teaching me how to make a budget
and then the next day uh i guess because
i looked up budget uh
you came up and you were and you were uh
uh
you're you're getting fired up over
somebody trying to uh finance a tv at
best buy
and i and i and i i found that hilarious
but
like i found there was like a lot of
merit what you're saying and uh
bought your book right in a night and uh
that's all it took
i love how a graduate student doing
research in mechanical engineering heard
a professor
and then heard dave and still thought
i'm gonna go with dave
yeah i love it
well you don't get good rants out of
college professors like that
yeah they just they don't come off
anymore yeah well well done sir how does
it feel now that you're free
uh liberating so what did you get out of
the total money makeover when you read
it all in one night
that that uh that you actually did
so when somebody says okay well if i
read that book what am i gonna learn
that's gonna help me get out of that
what did you do
it was really like uh a mental shift
like it wasn't like
uh it like you know like like you said
if you were doing like uh
if you were doing math uh like you would
have been dead in the first place
so it's really the mental shift that
like you know you're never gonna borrow
money again
and you're going to be on a written plan
from now on
yeah yeah well well done so i've i've
worked exclusively with graduate
students i've been a graduate professor
myself i've
i've i've met a number of students in
your situation
and it's hard to exist sometimes on
on those on those grad student stipends
yeah
how did you manage to do that and
be so focused on both your studies and
pan off your debt
it it was really like i mean like i mean
like i said it was like cutting
everything to the bone like it was like
uh
like moving back home like only buying
food like that was a
the great value brand uh like cutting my
own hair
like i mean like it was like i wasn't
going to say anything but you did a good
job man
yeah yeah yeah you should have seen
whenever i first did it
but uh yeah no it was like it really was
like just cutting everything to the bone
but like
by doing that and not spending like
anybody at all like going out to eat or
going out with friends
it really made me focus on my studies
too like and focus on my work
so like my work and like my focus was
i like all my work was like really
improved by doing the program i'm
usually in awe
of the folks on the debt free stage just
personally mm-hmm
i you're a superstar my friend man
you have pulled off and it's you know
nineteen thousand dollars
making thirty two making it for six
months with six thousand out of savings
that's very impressive well being a
student and an employee of the
university too that's just
extraordinary and proud of you man very
well done who were your biggest
cheerleaders
uh mom and dad they were they're the
biggest
cheerleaders they were very skeptical at
first uh like you know whatever i was
telling them that uh there's a bald man
on the radio in tennessee giving
financial advice
he cuts his own hair yeah yeah hey wait
till you call your parents and tell them
you're going to go work for that bald
man that's all
[Laughter]
man i'm proud of you aaron well done
very well done aaron
i'm proud of you too sir it's very
impressive what you pulled off and that
it sets you up to do so many other
things later because it builds a level
of confidence doesn't it
oh yeah like i mean now i could go
anywhere like you know
sky's the limit like where i can like
practice engineering
like so what is your so engineering is
your future career oh yeah
definitely yeah definitely how far out
before you start that uh
well i mean like i may be going on for a
phd here we'll see but for right now
it's just a masters so
i mean like going to the workforce maybe
like you know another three or four
years but
again so you're going to go and do
engineering or you're going to teach it
um have i really decided that yet
yeah yeah but the cool thing is you can
do whatever you want because you don't
own anybody any money
exactly yeah yeah so i mean yeah
gives you a lot of wiggle room man well
done very well done
all right aaron from the pittsburgh area
19
000 paid off in six months making 32 000
a year count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three
two one i'm debt free
yay
[Applause]
well done dave the
the average listener will not know how
hard what he did
actually was he swam upstream
in a culture with no water i don't know
how
i i'm just in awe of what he pulled off
while also going to school i mean he
literally had to cut everything i'm
moving back home with my parents i'm
going to do nothing
i'm going to cut my own hair that's a
guy that said i'm going to make the
change now
and what he did was really impressive
well because no one around him no one no
i was doing that and the math didn't
work right
it was if he had come to me i would have
said hey man why don't you wait till
after school
and he said nope i'm gonna do it now and
went to
all like you know all the great links to
go to to get this thing done man it's so
impressive
it is um i remember when i was a kid
uh going to a sales conference with my
parents
and the guy was a positive thinking guy
you know
and at first i was really really
enamored with that and then i went
through a period of time in my 20s
where um i'm like you cannot positive
think your way
into everything i can't grow hair just
on my head just because i'm positive
think i'm not gonna
uh add a foot to my stature and be able
to play in the nba as a result
um you know just because of positive
things so you can't positively think
your way into
everything and so i kind of just set all
that stuff aside and
turn it off but the more i do this in
this chair over the last 25 years
the more i realize that belief that you
can do it
is more important that's called hope
belief that you can do it is called hope
is more important than the math
it's that idea that yeah i no matter
what i'm going to keep moving forward
well i mean because i'm having to ask
him because the math didn't work right
i mean he did not make nineteen thousand
six months how do you pay off
19 000 you couldn't do it it's
mathematically impossible well oh by the
way
savings out in my undergrad i saved some
money yeah my first year in grad school
i saved some money yeah
so i had this six thousand dollars and
that changes the equation and then he
lived on literally
beans and rice rice it means it's very
very impressive but all of that stems
from
i'm going to do extreme things because i
believe
i hope i have hope that
i believe that the result of planting
corn is that corn is going to grow i
believe the result of this is i can see
the math that i'm going to be out
in six months seven months five months
whatever it is
so i'm going to walk five miles a day to
get water for that corn i'm gonna keep
watering it i'm gonna keep watering it
people are gonna say i'm crazy because i
believe i'm gonna be tired
but if you don't believe right then you
start going well
you know people like me can't get ahead
and let let america lis
listen directly from an engineering
graduate student it's not about the math
it's about the psychology it's about the
heart
in that interest he can do the math talk
about a guy that can do the math but
it's just like man i had to get my heart
rate
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 9 9
instruct the wise
and they will be wiser still teach the
righteous
and they will add to their learning
george patton said accept the challenges
so you can feel
the exhilaration of victory
amen open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money dr john deloney ramsey
personality
is my co-host today max is i'm sorry
mitchell is with us
in chattanooga hi mitchell welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hey john hey dave um quick question i'm
in the tail end of baby step two and
i have a car lease or a fleece as you
would put it and the turn in
is in june so i'm wondering if i should
pause
where i'm at on the baby steps i have
obviously baby step one done but should
i pause baby step two
to stack cash toward buying a new or a
vehicle after i turn it in
and cover any expenses that i would have
at the end of that fleece yes
buy a 2000 or three thousand dollar car
yes have them try to sell me this thing
yeah finance yes okay you're
right on that's a really brilliant idea
you've properly looked into the future
and avoided an emergency that really
shouldn't have been an emergency because
you thought about it six months ahead of
time five months ahead of time
you're gonna be able to do this well
done yes that's exactly what you should
do
right now thank you thank you sir there
is a principle there
that christmas should not be an
emergency
they don't move it right it doesn't
surprise anybody this lease is coming up
that you know you're in the fall you're
gonna go to school
these are not new pieces of information
and so you know develop some kind of a
game
plan and that's what he was doing is
shuffling you know high moving the shell
around hiding the p till
we find a game plan to figure this out
so i don't know i'm gonna get a car i
can't be walking i can't turn this thing
in i don't want to finance this thing
i don't want to keep it it needs to go
away and how am i going to do that i
can't say oh so i'm going to stop
beautifully done good critical thinking
but people don't look out past
freaking friday i was going to say i i i
have not read a book on it i could
probably call a buddy of mine that's got
some theory on it dave but you've done
this for a long time what
what is this where there is no vision
the people perish
when you don't look out past friday
everything yeah yeah
it's the car lease it's christmas it's
you're gonna die have a will it's that
your kid's gonna go to some sort of
secondary
i mean it's everything one definition of
maturity though is just the ability to
delay pleasure the ability to look into
the future and go
i this should not be a surprise the
tires wearing out on your car
are a hundred percent probability that's
going to occur an oil change coming up
is
for sure gonna have a hundred percent
probability and so you shouldn't need
oh the tire suddenly went out on my car
i mean you wouldn't believe the number
of times i had somebody
that the tires suddenly went out on
their car so they traded cars
[Laughter]
max is with us in seattle hey max
welcome to the dave ramsey show
uh yes hi dave hey john so uh i'm 17
i'm a high school senior right now and
so i'll be a freshman at my state school
as a business finance major
and i'll be living with my parents
during this time and so i have a
guaranteed full ride for all four years
and uh this year after tuition and fees
i'll have about 10 grand
left over scholarships for the first
year and so my question is what should i
do with this web server money
should i save it for after caller should
i invest it or
give away part of it that's my question
put it in a savings account to keep
going to school with
that's right man you may want to get an
opportunity to study abroad you may get
an opportunity to
do an internship you gotta something
else may fall through and you may need
this money
right 100 to be invested in max's
education
nothing else and i can tell if you're if
you're a business finance major who's
got a full ride that means you're a
person who thinks ahead just like we're
just talking about
don't overthink this just put in a
savings account and have it there
available for you when you need it
because you're going to need it here's
the math for you max
you completing the degree and completing
it debt free
is much more valuable exponentially more
mathematically
financially uh valuable
than you can make on a mutual fund okay
you put ten thousand dollars in mutual
fund you make a thousand bucks max is
worth a lot more than a thousand bucks
because max is a freaking bright student
and he's got a degree not in underwater
basket weaving coming up or left-handed
puppetry
he's got a degree that's very usable in
the marketplace so you finish this
degree you finish it on time
because you keep looking ahead you make
sure you take the freaking classes
necessary to graduate
on time it's amazing it's a whole nother
story and
uh and you keep this money set there now
let's say you go all the way through and
you never need the money and the money's
still sitting there
well then it's there to help you start
your new job with a new apartment in the
new city
maybe buy a little bit of a better car
or something after
you graduate but you are the secret
sauce in this equation
you are worth more finishing this degree
than any mutual fund will ever pay you
i'm ashamed to say this dave because i
had never
done the lost sunk cost math here but i
was sitting with a group of folks in a
think tank working through the
the how do we lower the cost of higher
education and there's a million
different options table
and one of them was get out early
because you don't do the math not only
on the cost of this education but on the
lost
costs of unearned wages and i went to
the university of tennessee with my
oldest daughter the first one to go to
college i'm sitting in the freaking
freshman orientation
and they go well 57
or 52 or whatever it is graduation rate
and uh
of the ones that graduate only 25
do it in four years oh yeah that 50 is
on a six year graduation rate right
and so yeah and so i reach over on her
notes
and wrote in big letters have a freaking
plan i mean when i was in school they
gave us a catalog i'm sure it's on
digital now
but you look and you go these are the
classes i need to take and they are all
offered during the four-year period you
can't schedule that
how do you qualify for a college degree
but dave i don't want to get so late you
want to get up before 11 a.m
and yeah eight o'clock classes bother me
because my beer pong gets interrupted at
11 p.m the night before
all right give me a hard time by 4 p.m
so i don't take any afternoon
don't get me started because you know by
the way that extra year costs money
that's what i'm saying
you can take a full load and not even a
full load but then graduate in four
years
but it costs 100 percent of the degree
fields it costs
25 grand let's say that's on the low end
but if you were gonna go make 45 grand
as at a job it cost you that too because
you're not working
right there's a there's a cost on top of
that that's true
and that's where when i thought oh my
gosh it's
this it's the tuition plus the fact that
this five-year plan
i mean i'm sorry if you graduate in five
years you can be pissed at me if you
want
but every all three of my children
graduated in four years
because i said 100 of the money stops
at the four-year mark and i'm gonna kick
your little college butt
i mean unbelievable well especially have
a plan you could go to high school now
and do dual credit courses you can just
so many
options you can take you can get down
five years with a master's degree now so
i worked 40 to 60 hours a week when i
was in school
yeah and graduated in four years so cry
me a freaking river
get done seriously get her done you know
why i graduated four years because i
didn't have the money to keep going i
didn't want to keep going i wanted to
get up and make money
right you know it's like i was so broke
i couldn't breathe
getting through i didn't want to live
that life anymore it was not a
it was it wasn't party central no it was
not living on my daddy's fret and my
daddy's frat and my daddy's fret paying
the bill it's not
unbelievable man it's unbelievable
so you got you gotta go to school so
higher education you know you can blame
these universities if you want or you
can blame your lazy butt for not
following the dadgum syllabus
well nowadays you can take 30 60 hours
in high school
for free yeah a community college for
free
right and then roll in and be out in 18
months or 24 months if you want to
and then hit the workforce and get ready
to rock so you get a four-year degree
effectively in two years the number of
students coming in with 30 to 60 hours
it was it was impacting the college
bottom line because kids were taking the
classes in their high schools ap classes
that's right
everyone's just dual credit courses yeah
oh they're dual credit ap and
configure it or clap out it goes all the
way back to talk a minute ago
just the number of parents i would talk
to over the years
good people that just suddenly went oh
my kid's a
senior well they gotta go to college
next year yeah yeah
it's a surprise they just showed up
that's right christmas is in december
that's that's such a great one hey don't
move it christmas is in december
good show john good job james childs
kelly in the booth well done i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
[Music]
jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit
daveramsey.com show and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell your story
[Music]
you